hey there wordsmiths this video is about
the word impose
impose it's a verb and it means to force
something onto others kind of like how I
impose my taste in music on you in these
videos you didn't ask for this I just
put it on to you which is indeed what
this word literally means in Latin comes
from two parts IM or in which can mean
in or on and poned which means to put so
let me impose my taste on you by giving
you a 10 second music break during which
time I would like for you to list out as
many words that contain im or pose as
you can ready let's do it to it
[Music]
all right here are some I came up with
earlier position where you put something
where it's located
impression and impact a dent when you
make a big impression you're literally
saying you pressed into something like a
big impression in the sand or the snow
figuratively it's an idea that occurs to
you as easily as making a dent in sand
oppose right this word means to be
against something to put yourself
against it
anyway impose it means to put something
on someone but it's not used literally
you wouldn't say I imposed a bucket on
Steve's head sorry Steve because you
wouldn't do that so I guess I'm not
sorry Steve because that didn't happen
it is a figurative meaning a non-literal
meaning do you think the new principle
will impose a ban on junk food it's more
like you're putting in a new rule
another meaning of imposing is being
impolite it's a common expression to say
I don't want to impose right I don't
want to be an inconvenience I don't want
to waste your time put myself in your
way you see I don't want to impose but
could you look after my giant spider
this weekend
you don't even need to walk her come on
she's so sweet her name is Benjamin
another form that this word can take if
we want to make it a noun is imposition
it's a big imposition for me to look
after this man-eating spider
wordsmiths I would never ask you to
watch my giant spider man eating or
otherwise but I would impose on you by
asking that you be so kind as to watch
the next vocabulary video I make
you can learn anything
David out